it's the hilarious pamela atlan
yes thank you
i can't believe i'm here i don't know
what we're doing let's go sous chef okay
let's go
you are in the driver's seat all right
um i will say on your show
um better things you do cook a lot yes
um and you cook in real time on the show
right yeah we cook like you chop and
like cut fingers and like you cook for
real roll on the cut roll on the blood
all of it yes that's i mean i don't know
what kind of bizarre sick funny
hilarious thing we have but everything
is like get it get the blood let's film
yes
and um
rosie you're going to teach us your
white fish casserole recipe um take it
away all right so this recipe i stole
from somebody and made it better
so that's the way to do it that's the
only way you get 15 to 20 these should
be roman tomatoes you skin them you
deceive them and you chop them up you
take two big uh spanish
onions and you do the same you put it in
here you saute them until it comes down
here's my secret ingredient why it's
better cinnamon baby holla and so you're
gonna put this like this
all throughout
and i know it sounds weird but it's
gonna taste so so good you let that cook
down and then you take white wine with
white wine hair is it this yeah and by
the way you're going in i do that
in the demo you're the yeah this is
white wine um so you pour the white wine
in here right line and you let it cook
down
right while this is going you're going
to start with your redstone uh potatoes
you're going to boil them slice them
olive oil them is this olive oil yes it
is okay you're going to olive oil them
like this and put salt and pepper like
this and then you go like that so okay
and then when that's done and you mix it
all up right you're going to take your
fish you're going to salt and pepper
your fish very very very very generously
right flavor and you're going to put a
lot of salt on it like this
okay and then you're going to take lemon
juice a whole lemon and a quarter cup of
um whatchamacallit olive oil olive oil
and you're going to stir it up and see
what happens
it gets emulsified
and then you're gonna pour it all over
the yummy yummy mmm look at that look at
that fattening yeah i love it okay you
put there like that you let that sit and
now you're gonna start layering as if
it's a lasagna and what you're going to
do you're going to take one scoop of the
mixture your sauce mixture you put it on
the bottom oh okay
right so now you're going to layer the
potatoes on right in your thing you're
going to take your fish flounder you
could use flounder i like flounder but
you could also use orange ruffy
but flounders better flounder i love it
it looks like the letter q yes foods
that begin with the letter f or o
yes okay so you layer this like that and
you're going to put another layer of
this
mix right then you're going to be
bubbling this much rose
this is panko but you could use italian
seasoned breadcrumbs that makes it even
better
um and so you're gonna go like these
generously
you do three layers of this until like
your your casserole dish is finished and
full and you're going to go ahead and
put it in the oven you're going to put
it in the oven at 4 25 and you're going
to let it bubble up
until it's bubbled up until it comes out
like this
we get the other side with him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is
so gorgeous and it tastes so good oh we
have to do plates okay do this wrong do
you put the potatoes on the thing
are we finishing this layering yes it's
already made
oh thank you oh yeah
ready um
cheers cheers yeah cheers cheers thank
you so much i can't believe this is
crazy
here's to women
[Applause]
that's exactly right
perfect
i feel like i won a contest
you get to cook with rosie perez and
drew barrymore this is crazy this is
perfect
and and you don't even notice the
cinnamon but it gives that
the cinnamon's a nice something chef's
kiss
that's so good if i should say so myself
but i will say nothing compares to
getting to be with the two of you this
is a dream come true it's a surreal
awesome dream of perfection i thank you
both for this moment we agree i thank
the show for creating moments like this
and rosie perez
you can get this recipe um on the
drewberrymart show.com and the season
two of the flight attendant um premiered
last week and you can catch new episodes
every thursday on hbo max
[Music]
you